this is the Mediterranean Sea one of the
world's deadliest migration routes
connecting Africa with Europe that's a
cup size rubber boat German volunteers
have been monitoring the area for hours
by plane they've spotted the remains of
a vessel just off the Libyan coast but
there's nobody in sight it's unclear
what's happened to the people who must
have been in the dinghy
hi Maria and Yan patrol the
Mediterranean in their aircraft moonbird
on behalf of German NGO Sea watch they
look out for migrants who set off from
Libya aboard unseaworthy vessels trying
to reach Europe
it's perilous and often fatal even when
the boats would stand the journey people
who are out at sea for days tend to be
massively dehydrated in complete despair
and in very poor health there are often
dozens of people with medical
emergencies who need to be evacuated as
fast as possible
footage of a previous rescue mission
it's common for migrants to be crammed
into inflatable vessels without food and
at the mercy of the elements the people
smugglers who see them off couldn't care
less but even when Maria and her team
spot a migrant boat in distress it
doesn't mean the refugees are safe all
the team can do is monitor the situation
and call for help there are almost no
private rescue ships in this area
anymore because of Italy's tough stance
some crews have been tried for people
smuggling and their vessels have been
seized and merchant ships like this tend
to avoid the area which often leaves the
Libyan Coast Guard to save people's
lives it's frustrating for the Seawatch
crew I want these people to reach a safe
harbor and to reach Europe I want them
to safely cross the sea and not get
deported leader we run our rescue ships
being impounded and fewer resources for
rescue missions available were the only
ones left monitoring the sea and then we
get into situations like this Maria and
Kai know that their every step is
closely watched by the Italian and
Spanish governments some accused
Seawatch of cooperating with people
smugglers who send migrants out to sea
but Maria says this is ludicrous
via food namaz mclaren we would never
communicate or cooperate with people
smugglers smugglers are criminals who
make money from people in despair they
make a profit from people who are so
desperate that they turned to smugglers
listen I've sensitivity they say every
life is equal and every person in
distress must be saved without exception
Maria is a medical student who
previously served on a rescue vessel it
had a huge impact on her
I'm sure far when I was serving on that
ship there was a mother who gave birth
on a rubber dinghy those are stories you
can't forget to have a baby in a rubber
boat out at sea without any help in
those filthy conditions that's beyond
anything you could ever imagine
that just sticks with you this aside for
hanging lights it's stories like these
that spur these volunteers on although
they face an uncertain future they're
plain moonbird has been banned from
operating from Malta for two years and
Seawatch fears other countries may
follow suit that's why we must keep it a
secret where their plane is currently
based for now the crew wants to keep
patrolling the Mediterranean Sea for as
long as they can and help save as many
lives as possible
you